chiva cocido los precios asustan los
guaraníes se cuentan por millares pero
cuando se hace el cambio al Dólar no es
para tanto la mayoría de los productos
en este mercado viene de Argentina no el
guaraní acá acá la comparación de o sea
el cambio con el peso está buenísimo
nuestro guaraní es la moneda más estable
de Sudamérica
como vos decís pase ha pasado muchas
cosas en el Paraguay pero por lo menos
su moneda sigue todavía estable
el museo de numismática en la sede del
Banco Central de Paraguay reconstruye la
historia de esta moneda que en Octubre
cumple 80 años
en nuestra historia es muy inestable con
muchas guerras internas y dos guerras
internacionales muy grandes que fueron
la de la Triple Alianza que fue una
pelea contra Argentina Brasil y este
Uruguay este conflicto aniquiló la mitad
de la población y mató al 90% de los
varones en edad militar paradójicamente
la inestabilidad política dio origen a
la moneda más estable de Sudamérica a
día de hoy no se sabe por qué decidieron
bautizarla con el nombre del pueblo
indígena lo que cuenta la gente es que
el decreto tenía que salir a la mañana y
a medianoche no sabían todavía Qué
nombre ponerle entonces ahí alguien se
le ocurrió y salió el nombre guaraní que
es en este momento la moneda cuya
denominación es la más antigua después
del peso colombiano verdad en América
Latina en el Banco Central confían en
que una eventual victoria de la
oposición no afectaría la moneda ya
hubieron un cambio político de cambio de
gobierno en la época de Lugo el doctor
Franco etcétera y la economía sigue por
su camino no creo que haya ningún
inconveniente con el guaraní el mercado
internacional en este momento es el que
más influencia tiene en este momento
para facilitar las transacciones
monetarias en 2009 surgió un proyecto
para quitar tres ceros al guaraní que da
por ver si el nuevo gobierno retomará un
proyecto que suscita dudas por miedo que
genere aún más inflación